cololis à oser on compte plutôt sur les
jeunes talents qui montent dernier
exemple en date Éric Cantona Gérard
Ferran nous dresse son
portrait
écantonin taille 1 M86 le poids 80 kg
poids de forme et c'est souvent le PO de
forme euh ouais ça va ouais pour le
moment ça va cette année ça va oui cette
année ça va témoin cette passe lumineuse
pour ferrer qui a déboussolé les Nanta
mais avant d'en arriver là eric a connu
sa traversée du désert à 17 ans et demi
il jouait son premier match pro avec
laagia en 85 à Strasbourg il inscrivait
son plus beau but et puis en 9586 il lui
faut retrouver le pays martig pour se
refaire une santé morale on m'a
accueilli là-bas comme le sauveur
d'ailleurs ce qui m'a étonné et puis on
comptait beaucoup sur moi quoi et et
tous les matchs tous les matchs tous les
matchs c'était moi moi qu'il fallait
qu'il fasse la différence je l'ai pas
trop faite quoi mais on s'est sauvé
c'est le principal et puis ça ça m'a
apporté beaucoup de choses sur le plan
moral revenu à osser en ce début de
saison il a changé mû son amour du
ballon en a fait un bon technicien un
attaquant qui pèse sur les défenses
guirou s'emploit maintenant à lui faire
travailler la
finition la confiance de guirou on là
quand quand on fait quelque chose sur le
terrain c'est pas c'est pas des paroles
si si en début de saison j'avais pas
confirmé les les espoirs que avait qui
qui fondait à moi et il aurait rien eu
je serais en 3è division encore en ce
moment Bernard Ferrer révèle une autre
raison à cette
métamorphose il s'est apparemment très
bien casé puisque il est fiancé avec ma
sœur et je pense que c'est une bonne
chose car il s'entend très bien tous les
deux et et maintenant je pense qu' qu'il
va qu'il va un peu ça va lui faire du
bien d'ailleurs d'être un peu un peu
casé et il vit loin du stade et de ce
public versatille qu'il veut apprendre à
oublier
dans un petit village en père pénard il
a sa maison il a Isabelle venue de la
Provence natale comme Joël bat il écrit
des poèmes comme Papa Cantona il peint
tu as vu ce que j'ai écrit je te le
l dans ce monde où les gens se taisent
si par malheur la raison s'apaise que
les crit de désespéré se fasse entendre
même si personne ne peut comprendre il
n'y a pas de folie il n'y a pas de
limite à la folie du temps quand le
bonheur nous
surprend
[Musique]
la vie équilibrée qui permet de de mieux
s'exprimer sur le terrain c'est c'est
tout ça toute cette ambiance ici c'est
toute cette ambiance c'est tout c'est
c'est ma copine Isabelle là qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure
c'est c'est c'est ou effectivement c'est
ça c'est la campagne c'est la nature
c'est c'est tout pour oublier le
football difficile d'oublier ce début de
gloire ce maillot bleu espoir ces buts
par exemple qui ont terrassé les
Soviétiques pour préserver sa sérénité é
s fait
yogi et quand on lui parle de la grande
équipe de France er reste sur la réserve
il n'a que 20 ans sil y en a qui parl
d'équipe de France c'est c'est le
problème mais moi c'est sûr que si ça
arriver ça me ferait plaisir quoi si ça
arrivait ça me ferait plaisir mais mais
pour le moment c'est pour le moment même
par la suite si un jour je viens tout ça
c'est pas ça qui va me qui va me tourner
la tête je pense
pas